[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
منظمه حقوقيه ايرانيه تؤكد وفاه احد
المتظاهرين المعتقلين متاثرا باصابات خطير
ناتجه عن التعذيب
اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص يسوتون بنعم من اجل
تنحل ملياردير الى الماسكان رئاسه تويتر
السجن 111 عاما لعصابه غسيل اموال بينها
السعوديه وزوجها الوافد بتوع من احتلال
الملك
في الرابعه ايضا
العربيه تتجول في قريه مسفاه العبريين احد
اشهر او احدى اشهر القرى التراثيه
والسياحيه في سلطنه عمان
البدايه من الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث كشف
موقعه حقوق الانسان الكردي هانغاو عن وفاه
احد المتظاهرين المعتقلين ويدعم محمد حاج
رسولبور المعتقل لرسول بورفي دخل في
غيبوبه بمستشفى في مدينه بوكان بمحافظه
يدربيجان الغربيه بسبب خطوره اصابته ناجمه
عن التعذيب كما قالت المنظمه الحقوقيه
وكانت السلطات الايرانيه تعتقلته للمره
الثانيه في الثالث والعشرين من نوفمبر
الماضي
واخبرت عائلته بان الرسول سيكون ضيفا في
سجن بكان لبعض الوقت
النظام الايراني يوصل ارتكاب التجاوزات
بحق المعتقلين حيث اتهمت فتاه ايرانيه من
سكان مدينه شرود شمالا ايران في تصريحات
لصحيفه اندبندنت بالنسخه الفارسيه اتهمت
عناصر من الحرس الثوري والقوات البسيج
باغتصابها
الفتاه تدعني لوفر حسب الصحيفه اضافت بانه
جرح تجازها لمده اسبوع في مركز اعتقال غير
قانوني وخلال الاحتجاز تعرضت للاغتصاب على
يدي 10 عناصر يرتدون زي الباسيج والحرس
الثوري الايراني وفقا لصحيفه في نسختها
الفارسيه
وعلى الارض شهدت عده مناطق في العاصمه
طهران احتجاجات الليليه ضد النظام شملت
احيان منها ستارخان وشاهين الجنوبيه
وسعاده اباد ردد المتظاهرون الايرانيون في
العاصمه طهران عبارات مناهضه للنظام
وللمرشد الايراني علي خمري اعتدالك ايضا
بالتزامن مع احتجاجات اخرى في مشهد ثاني
المدن الايرانيه الكبرى بالاضافه الى
كرمشه الكرديه التي شهد تحت متفرقه ردد
بها المتظاهرون شعارات مثل الموت
للديكتاتور
جنوبيه
[موسيقى]
سبونج بوب
في ايران دعى عمال النفط في عسلاويه
وكنكان العاملين في قطاعات الحفر والتشغيل
والوقود والمصافي والبتروكيماويات دعاهم
الى الانضمام الى الاحتجاجات والدخول في
الاضراب للتعبير عن الموقف من عقوبه
الاعدام التعسفيه بحق المحتاجين
هذا وقد بدا عدد من اصحاب المحاله
التجاريه في مدينه سنندج وكاميران في
محافظه كردستان ايران بداوا اضرابا عن
العمل واغلقوا متاجرهم
[موسيقى]
فارس
سويتها اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص بنعم من اجل
تنحي ملكه تويتر الجديد الى الناس كان
الرئاسه وشكلت نسبه المصوتين بنعم 57 ونصف
من المئه في المئه من اجماله المستويتين
الذين تجاوز عددهم 17 مليون و500,000 شخص
صورته في الاستفتاء الذي استمر 24 ساعه
وكان ايران ما ازكاك كاد انه يرتدي سيلتزم
بنتيجه التصويت مهما كانت
من بيروت ينضم الينا الدكتور بولمرقص
استاذ القانون الدولي رئيس منظمه جوستيا
الحقيقي دكتور بيقول مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه دكتور اولا هل كان هذا السؤال
وهذا الاستطلاع من لهن ماسك مفاجئا
للمتابعين لماذا طرحه اصلا في هذا التوقيت
هل كان يتوقع نتيجه مخالفه اصلا لما وصلت
اليه النتائج ما الغايه من ذلك
دعى الى استفتاء عبر المنصه نفسه وهذا
معيوب اصلا بمجرد انه هو الداعي الى هذا
الاستفتاء وهو الذي ينظم الاستفتاء وان
الاستفتاء يجري على المنصه التي تعود اليه
لكن مجرد الامر طبعا هذه خطوه باتجاه
تمكين المشتركين او المستخدمين من ابداءهم
عملا بما يدعو اليه دائما من الرجوع الى
الناس من اجل استنباط ارائهم وبالتالي
احترام حريه التعبير التي اتهم مع انه
خلقها وهو نفسه في الايام والاسابيع قليل
الماضيه عبر اطلاق حسابات همم صحفيين
بداعي انها فقط تجميد مؤقت همم
يعني تشميت حسابات منهم منافسين له او منو
حرض او يعني يسوق لي اعلانات لمنصات اخرى
ايضا هو طرح عددا من القضايا الساخنه
الحساسه مثل يعني نجل الرئيس بيدن وعلاقته
باوكرانيا ايضا مساله النساء مساله العمال
في التويتر وخفض
المعاشات والرواتب والعديد ايضا خفض
الميزانيه الامور الاخرى التي فعلا تعتبر
تحديات قالت الى هذا الوضع بعد ما تحول
الرجل الى شخصيه يعني اشكاليه اذا اردت
القول وربما اراد عبر هذا الانتقال المراد
ان يكون ديمقراطيا اراد ان يسلم احدا سوا
مرض عنه وفقا عليه وفقا اليه يعتبر هذه
ديمقراطيه من شانها ان تخفف من الاحتقان
وهذه الاشكاليه
الى الامر حتى يظهر بانه يستجيب لاراده
الناس
وليس لضغوط المستثمرين حوله الذين قد يرون
بانه ليس الحصان يعني الذي يمكن ان يكسب
الرهان في ادارته لهذه المؤسسه برايك اذا
هل النتيجه يمكن ان تكون مفاجاه ايضا مسك
نتيجه الاستطلاع
تدخل عوامل اخرى همم يعني من شانها تجنيد
عدد من المستخدمين على المنصه للتصويت في
هذا الاتجاه او ذاك رغم انني استبعد
دكتور يبدا انه فقدنا الاتصال بضيفنا من
بيروت
سنحاول العوده
مكتبه الملك عبد العزيز تطلق معرضا خاصه
للمخطوطات النادره التي تتناول علوم اللغه
العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد نعود الى موضوع تصويت
اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص بنعم من اجل تنحي
ملك تويتر الجديد لهن ماسكه عن الرئاس
نسبه المصوتين بنعم حتى الان 57 ونصف
المئه من اجمالي المصوتين الذين تجاوز
عددهم 17 مليون و500,000 شخص صوته في
الاستفتاء الذي استمر على مدى 24 ساعه
وانا اعود الى ضيفنا من بيروت الدكتور بول
المرقص استاذ القانون الدولي ورئيس منظمه
جوستسي الحقوق يا دكتور بول اود اليك
وسؤالي بالاضافه يعني الى الى انه في حدود
المتوقع ربما يتنحى همم لكن هل ذلك ممكن
فعليا هل هذه النتيجه التي يريد ان يصل
اليها الى الماسك من هذا همم
نعم اعتقد انه يريد ان يسلك اليه
الديمقراطيه وبالتالي اذا اراد فعلا ان
ينقل الاداره الى احد سواه من المرض عنهم
من قبله فانه سيقول الذاك انه يعني خضع
لاراده الاستفتاء واراده الجمهور وبذلك
يكون هذا التحول تحولا الديمقراطيا بينما
هو يخفي في حقيقه الامر رغبه لديه في نقل
يعني الاداره الى شخص اخر ولو انه نفق
مؤخرا ان يكون في ذهنه هذا الامر وقال ليس
لديه خليفه
الاجابات والتعليقات في هذا الاستطلاع لكن
ربما من اهمها من قال بان السؤال الذي
يترك الان وجديد بالطرح هل العثور على
مدير تنفيذي اخر كبير غير له الماسك يمكن
ان ينقذ هذه المنصه الشهيره من الحاله
حاله الانهيار التي يصفها الب بهذا الشكل
او يبقيها على قيد الحياه
من الحظوظ ولديها من الجداره
والقيمه بما يضمن استمرارياتها طبعا هذه
الاستمراريه تعرضت لبعض النكاسات لنقول
لكنها في المقلب الاخر ايضا زادت من
التفاعل يعني حديث المنصه لا زال همم
قائما على جدول وسائل الاعلام منذ شهور
عديده بسبب ان هذا الرجل تملك الاداره
والسحوذ على الحصص اللازمه همم للادارهم
وبالتالي فان رب ضاره نافعه يعني هذه
الاجواء التي تعبق في الاخبار المتعلقه
بميزانيه المنصه
بعلاقتها بالاداره الامريكيه وسائر الدول
حتى ان القوه المتحده والمانيا وسواها
ادانت منذ يومين يعني تصرف ماسك بشكل
الصحفيين يعني كل هذا اللقط ربما هو يعني
بشكل هو مضر الى اي ماده تدخلت السياسه في
هذا الامر سريعا دكتور بول
[موسيقى]
علاقه المحتدمه التي كانت
تنشب اكثر فاكثر مع الاداره الامريكيه
مساله تمسك ماسك بحريه التعبير وفقا
للتعديل الدستوري الاول بينما يظهر
المشرعون الامريكيون الى يعني الرقابه
اكثر فاكثر على وسائل الاعلام وعلى
المنصات الالكترونيه عبر التعديل القانون
المرجو الذي نتحدث عنه منذ الصينيين ولم
يقال لغايه التاريخ
على هذه المنصات يعني طبعا هذا التفاعل
همم تفاعل سياسي بالدرجه الاولى نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك من بيروت الدكتور مرقص استاذ
القانون الدولي رئيس منظمه ماجستير الحب
الحقيقي
اعلانات النيابه العامه في السعوديه صدور
احكام التقديم سجن مواطن وزوجها مواطنه
وزوجها الوافد واخرين مده 100 واحد عشره
عاما اكثر من 28 ريال
وحده
بتشكيل الاجرامي
عبر محاوله اقناعهم بالاستثمار في التداول
في العملات الافتراضيه واستثمارات
الخارجيه غير نظامي
التشكيل العصابي على حساباتهم البنكيه يتم
سحب المبالغ الماليه التي بها وتحويلها
الى اشخاص وحسابات وكيانات وهميه ومن ثم
الى خارج السعوديه
الاستديو ينضم الينا المحامي فهد القصيري
استفاد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
نريد ان اسال اولا لماذا وصل الحكم لهذا
الرقم الكبير 111 سنه
اولا انا سعيد جدا اني اكون معكم اليوم
للحقيقه عن هذا البيان الصادر من النيابه
العامه والمتوج بان النيابه العامه في
مواجهه الاحتيال المالي وقبل ذلك انه مثل
هذه الاحكام الرادعه والاحكام همم المنصفه
في في حقوق واموال المواطنين او المقيمين
على ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن ثم
يتطرق الى مسالتني اليه عن وصول الحكم الى
111 سنه همم مع ان الجريمه جريمه احتيال
المالي نجد ان البيان الصادر من النيابه
العامه نصف على ان الجريمه الموجوده هي
عباره عن عن عن خمس جرائم وصلت فيها
النيابه العامه بعد الاتهام بالاحتيال
المالي بعد التحقيق من قبل وحده النيابه
العامه المختصه في نظام الاحتلال المالي
والاجراءات الماليه
لمثل هذه الجرائم نجد انه تولد عن جريمه
الاحتيال المالي عدد من الجرائم على على
سبيل الحصر غسل الاموال التستر التجاري
مخالفه نظام الجرائم المعلوماتيه التزوير
وغسل الاموال مع وجود المخالفه الاساسيه
وهي مخالفه نظام الاحتيال المالي والوصول
الى اموال الاشخاص بطريقه غير مشروعه هذا
العدد من الجرائم اللي ذكرتها هل يجعل هذه
الجريمه همم
معقده في اكتشافها وبالتالي الوصول الى
الاحكام فيها او المتهمين ايضا فيها همم
ولله الحمد اننا نعم في في اجراءات الضبط
وفي جهات استدلال ممكنه باحدث الوسائل
والتقنيات للوصول الى الجنات ايا كان
مقرهم وبشكل السليم ونجد ان ان الجهات
الامنيه في جميع وسائلها استخدمت اسلوب
الوقايه قبل اسلوب العلاج والبحث عن
الجنايه نجد ان التحذيرات مستمره على قدم
وساق في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في
الاعلانات في في جميع الجهات الحكوميه قبل
الوصول الى الجنات الوصول الى الجنات فان
الجريمه المتحتمه هي جريمه الاحتيال
المالي ايا كان الوصف الجرمي التي ارد
ترتب عن الاحتيال المالي هو له بالمرصاد
سواء كان غسل الاموال او التزوير عند
الوصول الى الجنات كان من الساهل الوصول
للوقائع ومن ثم الاتهام بالادله المستندين
اليهم همم انت عندك فكره عن حجم مثل هذه
الجرائم الجرائم الاحتيال المال الموجود
اليوم كم محام يعني من خلال تجاربك
الشخصيه
من ناحيه التجارب الشخصيه اذا كلنا نتكلم
عن عن الاحتيال المالي خلينا ناخذها بنسبه
طرديه اذا كانت الدوله تنعم وتنتعش
اقتصاديا فاعلم انه هناك كيانات تستغل هذا
الانتعاش وهذا وهذا النعم الوفيره التي
ننعم بها ولله الحمد منه همم لا اخفيه كان
هناك عدد كبير من الذين يتعرضون لهجمات
للوصول الى اموالهم بطريقه غير مشروعه
سواء على سبيل الافراد او كانت التجاريه
في جميع الجهات تقريبا
بصفتي محامي على شكل شخصي همم اسبوعيا من
ثلاث الى اربع اتصالات
الناس تعرضوا الى جرائم تعرضوا الى جرائم
احتلال الماليه
اتصالات انهيك عن الاعداد المضاعفه ان هذه
الذين تعرفوا واحد اخر ممكن يحصل على عدد
اكبر طيب الناس اللي متضررين او يتصلوا
عليكم من الناس المتعلمين
ناس من عامه الناس
من جميع الطبقات لا تستطيع ان تحصرهم في
طبقه واحده يعني وان كان وان كان السائد
من الطبقات المتعلمه او من الطبقات الغير
متعلمه عذرا ان كان هذا المفهوم السائد
عندنا ولكن من جميع الطبقات يستخدمون
السلوب اقناعي
يستخدموا همم هو بطريقه يستطيع او لا
يستطيع احد يقول لك مثلا
ممكن يعطيك رباح خلال يومين ثلاثه ايام
اوصل الى 15 20,000 مثل هذا مع انه واضح
انه في مشكله يعني اي الان عادي طبيعي
يسمع هذا الامر
يعتقد انه في مشكله معينه ممكن تحصل لكن
كيف يستطيع هذا الشخص اقناع الاخر صحيح لا
لا ب- اا يعني اعطيك اياها بصوره مختصره
جدا كلما كان اسلوب الاقناع وممكن من
الشخص المقنع كان الوصول الى المعلومات
الشخص بطريقه اسرع واسهل بمعنى يستخدمون
وسائل تقنيه مستحدث لديهم بمعنى يتصل على
متصل ياتيك رمز سري الان مكون من اربع
ارقام اثناء الاتصال ياتيه الرمز السري
الرمز السري هذا مكمل فيقول هذه جهه هي
جهه رسميه دائما البنوك نجده من البنك لا
يطلب منك الرقم السري دائما نجد ان
الايميل والارقام السريه هي عائده لك لا
تعطيها لاشخاص اخرين اثناء الاتصال يمرر
له معلومات اثناء الاتصال تكون المعلومه
لدي فيظن ان هي الجهه الرسميه والجهه
الممكنه ثانيا استخدم الاسلوب الذي يكون
هو اسلوب البشر بالطبيعتهم
اسلوب الطمع كل ما ممكن من الطمع احيانا
نبادر بعشره الاف ومن ثم يعيدها له ل
15,000 نجد ان البيان الصادر من النيابه
العامه تحدث عن الجزئيه هذه بصوره بسيطه
وبنمط بسيطه قال يتم تحويل اموال المجني
عليهم فيما بينهم ظنا منهم انها اربعه
عائده لهم وهذه هي في الواقع اللي موجوده
امامنا اليوم كانت بهذه الطريقه يستطيعون
الوصول الى اموال المواطنين او المقيمين
او المجني عليهم بصفه عامه على ارض
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودائما ابدا
يكون والاعلان او يكون التحذير ان
المعلومات السريه هي معلومات خاصه بك لا
تزودها لاي اتصال وارد اليك هل يمكنك
العقوبه همم
الاعتراف مثلا في في وضع معين حسب الماده
الثامنه همم حسب الماده الثامنه من النظام
الاحتيال المالي نصت على انه للمحكمه
الاعفاء من العقوبه في حال بادر احد من
الجنات بالابلاق قبل وقوع الضرر وقبل
العلم السلطه وكذلك نجد ان نجد ان المنظم
المشرع لما كان يتكلم عن الانظمه ليس
الهدف منها العقوبه وليس الهدف منها الالم
وليس الهدف منها هو الهدف منها التقديب
والردع والحر على المال العام والاعفاء
موجود في النظام متى ما قام المجني او
الجانب الابلاغ قبل علم السلطه وقبل وقوع
الضرر فيمكن للمحكمه النظر في الاعفاء من
العقوبه شكرا جزيلا لك في هذا القصيري
المحامي اشكرك على تواجدك عافاك الله
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضه طلقت مكتبه
الملك عبد العزيز العامه مع رضا خاصه
للمخطوطات العربيه النادره التي تتناول
علوم اللغه العربيه
وفنونها
ومعجمها وذلك بمناسبه الاحتفاء باليوم
العالمي للغه العربيه يضم المعرض مجموعات
النادره من المخطوطات التي تعنى باللغه
العربيه من البرازيها مخطوطه كتاب النوادر
لابي زيد بن اوس الانصاري وهي واحده من
اقدم واندر المخطوطات في اللغه العربيه
وتعرض المكتبه ايضا في معرضها مخطوطه
للمعجم الشهير لابي نصر الجوهري تاجر
اللغه وصححه العربيه وغيرها ايضا من
المخطوطات النادره
يقيموا مركز الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي
اثراء حفل اثراء المحتوى في مركز الملك
عبد الله المالي في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض الاربعاء المقبل سيشهدوا الحفل
يتلقى النسخه الثانيه من مبادره المحتوى
العربيه التي تتضمن سبعه مجالات منها
الافلام الوثائقيه الادب ترجمه
الالكترونيه الموسيقه وغيرها من المجالات
مبادره المحتوى العربي تادف الى تطوير
المحتوى فضلا عن توفير فرص متنوعه في
القطاعات الثقافيه والابداعيه في السعوديه
وظفت الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي سدايه تقنيات تستخدم
خوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعيه في فهم اللغه
العربيه
تدفوس بدايه من هذه الخطوه الى اثراء
المحتوى العربي في مجالات البيانات
والذكاء الاصطناعي وتنميه الابحاث
والتطبيقات المتعلقه بذكاء الاصطناعي
واللغه العربيه
من رياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مرحبا بك عبد
المحسن وانت تتابع هذا الموضوع كيف يتم
توظيف هذه البيانات والخوارزميات في فهم
اللغه العربيه
نعم خالد بالفعل احتفال كبير قبل ذلك
باللغه العربيه من مختلف الجهات الحكوميه
السعوديه وحتى المكتبات وغيرها في هذا
اليوم في يوم الثامن عشر من سبتمبر او
ديسمبر ليوم اللغه العربيه في الحقيقه
هنالك عدد المبادرات عملت عليها الجهات
الحكوميه من هذه المبادره وهي توظيف هذه
المخطوطات وايضا كافه البيانات العربيه
لادخالها في الخوارزميات وايضا الاستفاده
من التقنيات الجديده لاعاده او والاستفاده
بشكل اكبر من كافه همم خدمات الالكترونيه
لخدمه اللغه العربيه ولكن اليوم خالد
اتواجد في مكتبه الملك عبد العزيز العامه
وهنا في هذه القاعه همم نعود بكم في زمن
الى ما يقارب 1000 سنه حيث المخطوطات
والنوادر والمعاجم العربيه التي يعود
تاريخها لاكثر من اا سنه وهناك همم
بالعوده الى هذه المخطوطات والنوادر
السعوديه خالد تمتلك 30% ما يقرب على 30%
من المخطوطات همم الاسلاميه والتاريخ
والارث الاسلامي في هذه الكتب وسنتحدث
اكثر مع الاستاذ عادل القاسم وهو مدير
الاداره الثقافيه في مكتبه الملك عبد
العزيز العامه عن هذا المعرض حدثنا في
البدايه الراحه فيك على شاشه العربيه
وحدثنا عن هذا المعرض الذي تقول منه
بالتزامن مع اليوم العالمي للغه العربيه
بس اكثر من 1500 سنه للمعلومه اللي اضفتها
طبعا تقوم مكتبه الملك عبد العزيز بدوره
ثقافي مميز همم في المجال المعرفي
والتعاون مع وزاره الثقافه والتعاون مع
الهيئات والجهات المختصه معرض همم
المخطوطات الخاصه باللغه العربيه
والاحتفاء باليوم العالمي للغه العربيه
والذي يصادف الثامن عشر مش عارف ديسمبر في
كل عام
المعرض يضم اكثر من 50 مخطوط تتحدث عن
اللغه العربيه وادبها في مختلف المجالات
همم يضم المعرض نوادر المخطوطات المختصه
لمخطوطات متعدده تتميز
بالنودره في همم هذه همم المخطوطات استاذ
عادل الان نشاهد في الصوره عدد من
المخطوطات اذا ممكن يعني همم حتى الغير
متخصص في في المخطوطات والغير عارف فيها
كيف ممكن ان همم تفسر لنا او تشرح لنا هذه
المخطوطات اللي همم ظاهره في الصوره وايضا
عناوينها واهميتها طبعا تتميز هذه
المخطوطات بوضوح الكتابه ووضوح الخط طبعا
متحدده الخطوط مختلفه الخطوط من المغرب
همم الوطن العربي الى مشرق همم قاره اسيا
همم تتمتع ايضا بالنودره
بعضها ليله تاريخ 400 للهجره هذه
المخطوطات المتميزه التي تميزت بها
المكتبه
كم تملك المكتبه من مخطوطات وارقامها
بالنسبه للمخطوطات
المكتبه ولله الحمد غنيه بهذه المخطوطات
المتميزه لعل المكتبه في هذا
السياق المميز المكتبه تملك اكثر من 7000
مخطوط متميز وكلها معالجه وفق همم انظمه
معالجه تتم في ترميم هذه المخطوطات داخل
المكتبه من ضمن مركز ترميم كامل لهذه
المخطوطات همم والمعروض هنا المعروض هنا
اكثر من 50 مخطوط كلها تتحدث عن اللغه
العربيه وادابها شكرا
اذا 50 همم معروض فقط من اصل سبعه الاف
تملكه مكتبه الملك عبد العزيز العامه هذا
بخلاف كافه الجهات الثقافيه الاخرى التي
تملك كما قلت ثلاثين في المئه من الارث من
المخطوطات والنوادر العربيه
والاسلاميه على مدى الاكثر من 1400 سنه
خالد في تاريخ الاسلامي بدءا من امتداد ما
هي سواء كان من الصين وحتى المغرب العربي
خالد شكرا عبد المحسن
تستضيف مدينه جده غربيه السعوديه يوم غدا
الثلاثاء الاجتماع الاول لاجهزه انفاذ
قوانين مكافحه الفساد للدول الاعضاء في
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
يناقش الاجتماع المقرر ان يستمر يومين
مشروع اقرار اتفاقيه مكه المكرمه التي تعد
احدى مبادره السعوديه على الصعيد الدولي
والاقليمي وتدعم الاتفاقيه الجهود
المبذوله في مجال حمايه النزاهه وتعزيز
مبدا الشفافيه ومكافحه الفساد لتحقيق
التقدم والازدهار في المجتمعات الاسلاميه
اطلقت هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه في
السعوديه مبادره بعنوان دور جهازك تهدوا
في لاعاده تدوير الاجهزه الالكترونيه مثل
الهواتف المحموله والحواسيب المكتبيه
والطابعه وتستمر الى نهايه يناير القادم
المزيد في التقرير التاريخ
هيئه الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه المرحله
الثانيه من مبادره اعاده تدوير الاجهزه
دور جهازك والموجهه للافراد والتي تهدف
الى تحقيق الاستدامه البيئيه والحد من
الانبعاثات والمخلفات الالكترونيه وتقليل
الهدر المالي عبر اعاده تدوير الاجهزه
اكثر عن هذا الموضوع انضم الينا اليوم
قائد فريق اداره الاداء المهندس راكان
سليم حياك الله تحدث لي اكثر عن هذه
المبادره وما الهدف من اطلاق مثل هذه
المبادره اليوم الله يحييك استاذه
بتواجدكم معنا اليوم مبادره تدور جهازك
طبعا انطلاقا من توجهات الاستراتيجيه
الاحوال الاستدامه وتلبيه لرؤيه سمو سيدي
اطلقنا مبادره دور جهازك غير ربحيه طبعا
تعنا المبادره في همم في تدوير الاجهزه
الالكترونيه وهي مبادره غير ربحيه همم
ايضا تستهدف المبادره همم جوانب بيئيه
واقتصاديه واجتماعيه على الجانب البيئي
نستهدف تقليل اا انبعاثات الكربونيه
الناتجه من الاجهزه او المخلفات
الالكترونيه ايضا الجانب الاجتماعي سنساهم
في تعزيز مبادئ التكافل الاجتماعي وايضا
على الجانب الاقتصادي همم سنعزز مبادئ
الاقتصاد الدائري وتقرير الهدر المالي
طبعا اطلقت المرحله الاولى في سبتمبر من
هذا العام لقطاع الاعمال والحمد لله تكللت
بالنجاح حيث همم ساهم معنا اكثر من 20 جهه
او حصلنا على 36,000 جهاز بقيمه تقديريه
للتبرع بمليون ريال واليوم همم نطلق
المرحله الخاصه بالافراد ونتطلع ان شاء
الله استكمال هذا النجاح
ما هي الخيارات المطروحه امام الاشخاص
الذين يودون بتبرع اجهزتهم طبعا
بشراكه مع شركائنا
استطعنا ان نقدم خيارات متعدده للعملاء
بحيث انه يستطيع ان يقدم اما اصلاح
الاجهزه والتبرع بها او اتلاف الاجهزه
واعادتها الى مواد اوليه طبعا ايضا بسبب
تنوع شركاؤنا
يستطيع المشارك اما تسليم الجهاز همم عن
طريق نقاط التجميع او استلامها من موقع
العمل ماذا لو تحدثنا عن الخطوات المطروحه
بعد اتلاف الاجهزه من قبل الافراد اليوم
اكيد طبعا همم اعاده تدوير الاجهزه
واتلافها وتحويلها الى مواد اوليه مثل
النحاس والحديد والالمنيوم وغيرها ويتم
الاستفاده منها في صناعات اخرى همم الجانب
الاخر ايضا في جانب الاصلاح يوجد اجراء
مطول لتقييم الاجهزه
واعاده ضبطها
وضمان صلاحيتها وتبرع بها للجمعيات
الخيريه
ثم ايضا ان همم تنظروا الى عدد البيانات
الموجوده في جميع الاجهزه وكيف يمكن ان
نمشي في هذه الخطا ان نبحث عن جهاز معين
وننظر الى بياناته لو تحدثنا عن هذا
الموضوع البيانات اكيد موضوع حساس وحرسنا
عليه في جميع الخيرين اننا نغطي ف- اا في
جانب الاصلاح واصلاح اجهزه الكمبيوتر
حرسنا على توفير انظمه معتمده عالميه همم
تقوم باعاده ضبط الجهاز بما يسمى مدادا
ايضا همم بما يخص الاتلاف لانه يتم اتلاف
الجهاز بالكامل ولا يمكن اعاده اي بيانات
في هذا الموضوع ايضا حرزنا على توفير دليل
ارشادي في موقع المبادره همم سيساعد اي
مستخدم يرغب باعاده ضبط جهازك عن طريق
الموقع
في العاصمه الرياضيه ايضا يستمر معرض
القهوه السعوديه باستقبال الزوار في متحف
قصر المصمك كالذي يعد من ابرز معالم
التراث السعودي هذا المعرض الذي تختتم
فعالياته نهايه ديسمبر الجاري يتناول طرق
زراعه القهوه السعوديه
وتحميصها وتحضيرها مع استعراض الادوات
المستخدمه في التحضير قديما وحديثا لعادته
كل منطقه في السعوديه ضمن اقسام من عده
يمر بها زوار المعرب
متابع من المعرض معرض القهوه السعوديه
الرياض مع مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف
مرحبا بك اهم ما يجتمل عليه المعركه
نعم خالد معرض القهوه السعوديه يشكل فرصه
امام السعوديين وغير السعوديين من السياح
وغيرهم للتعرف على تاريخ القهوه السعوديه
زراعتها وتحضيرها وفقا لعادات وتقاليد كل
منطقه في السعوديه عادات اهالي المنطقه
طرق التحضير وايضا طرق الزراعه هذا المعرض
بدا في الخامس عشر من اكتوبر ولا زال
مستمر حقيقه باستقبال همم الزوار هناك
اقبال كبير يعني خاصه مع موسم شتاء
السعوديه ومع اقبال السياح سنطلع الان على
جزء من هذا المعرض كما تشاهد خالد هذا
القسم الاول ويسمى بفنجال الهيف وهذا همم
المسمى جاء لان الفنجال الاول الذي همم
يقدمه يقدم للضيف يشربه المضيف للتاكد من
جوده القهوه ولكي يطمئن الضيف ان القهوه
همم جيده هو غير مسمومه كما يسمى قديما
العديد من
الاقسام هنا متواجده خمس محطات يمر بها
الزائر هنا كما نشاهد همم الاشجار القهوه
مراحل نمو اشجار القهوه عاده يتواجد هنا
مزارع من اصحاب المزارع في مناطق السعوديه
خاصه من جازان التي تنتج كميات كبيره من
القهوه في محافظه الدائر وايضا المحافظات
الاخرى جازان وحدها خالد تنتج اكثر من
2040 طن سنويا من القهوه هذا بالاضافه الى
انتاج من همم منطقه عسير ومنطقه الباحه
والعديد من المناطق الاخرى الاقبال
المستمر همم نحن في نهايه عام القهوه
السعوديه 2022 الذي حقق في العديد من
الانجازات انشاء الشركه السعوديه القهوه
التابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات العامه وايضا
همم تسميه المقاهي والمطاعم بالقهوه
السعوديه لديها في قوائم الطعام
والمشروبات تفاصيل اكثر ربما في الاقسام
القادمه التي تعرف ايضا
بطرق تحضير القهوه والمطاحن وهناك ايضا
ورش عمل تقام للزوار شكرا لك نوف عزيز من
معرض القاهره في الرياض
في الرابع بعد الباص
في موسم الرياض مطعم افريقيا ايضا بنكهات
تناسب الزائر الخليج
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه وخصيصا
الموسم الرياضي
المطعم الافريقي الوحيد يتواجد في منطقه
ذا جروبس لتعريف الزوار بثقافه الافريقيه
من خلال الاكلات المختلفه ورقصات
الاستعراضيه التي تعكس هويه جنوب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
زواره على طريقه جنوب افريقيا بالتصاميم
الطبيعه وبموظفيه الذي جاء بعضهم من قبيله
الزولو كسم المطعم لابراز الهويه
الافريقيه
وده بني بني
اقدم خدماتي لهم رغم حاجز اللغه في بعض
الاحيان لكن في الغالب الامر ممتع
[موسيقى]
الطعم الافريقي كان مقدما باطباق تعكس
ثقافه الشعب الافريقي لكنه محضر بنكهه
تناسب ذوق زائر العربي والخليجي في موسم
الرياض
جبنا اطباق زي عندك في جنوب افريقيا
او السعوديه ايوه لقينا الحماس لقينا
الانفعال مع الاجواء
ولاول مره في السعوديه يكون في مطعم جنوب
افريقيا
فاول ما قد يخطر على ادهاننا هي الموسيقى
الافريقيه والرقص المطعم بالحركات السريعه
والابتسامات التي تؤثر زوار المطعم
وتجعلهم
رهينه السعاده خلال حجمهم فيه
[موسيقى]
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربيه
متر فوق مستوى سطح البحر على سفوح الجبال
المحيطه بولايه الحمراء ومناظرها الطبيعيه
الخلابه بالاضافه الى مبانيها القديمه
التي تعود الى مئات السنين وعلى مدار
سنوات الماضيه نجاح سكان القريه في جعلها
مقصدا سياحيا من خلال ترميم بيوت القريه
القديمه والتقليديه المصنوعه من الطين
وتحويلها الى فنادق صغيره عبد الرحمن
العسيري
[موسيقى]
ما صفات العبريين قريه تراثيه تمتد على
قمه جبل بارتفاع يزيد عن 1000 متر عن سطح
البحر وهي عباره عن مجموعه منازل تقليديه
متناثره في عشرات الازقه الصغيره المطله
على الاراضي المزروعه باشجار الليمون
والموز والحمضيات والنخيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مسافات العبريين واحده من القرى التي تقع
في ولايه الحمراء بسلطنه عمان والتي نجحت
في توظيف التراث لتتحول الى مقصد سياحي
يرتاده الزوار طوال العام هذا المكان
ينتظره الكثير من المشاريع السياحيه قريبه
[موسيقى]
اهالي القريه قاموا خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه بترميم بيوت قريه القديمه
والتقليديه المصنوعه من الطين وتحويلها
الى فنادق صغيره
[موسيقى]
طبعا العمل التراث السياحي عمل متري
ومتجدد واحنا اخذنا على اعتقنا في البلده
نكون هذه اسسها اجدادنا انه يجب علينا
واجب علينا المحافظه عليها
وابتدانا باول ناس في عمان بفكره نزل
التراثيه او الفنادق التراثيه وهي عباره
عن بيوت قديمه
[موسيقى]
القريه التراثيه هذه اصبحت وجهه لاصحاب
المشاريع الصغيره والمتوسطه لاستيعاب عدد
السياح المتزايد
الفكره كانت غريبه نوعا بمنطقه جبليه ولكن
مع كثره همم المشاريع السياحيه الحمد لله
رب العالمين لكن اقبال كبير وهمم
حتى الحين همم صار الاقبال اكثر
[موسيقى]
في ديسمبر من العام الماضي 20 21 ادرجت
قريته مسفاه العبريين ضمن قائمه منظمه
السياحه العالميه كواحده من اجمل القرى
السياحيه وذلك خلال اجتماع الجمعيه
العموميه لمنظمه السياحه العالميه في
العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من ولايه الحمراء العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حراره الشمس تسبب فوارق ضغطيه يتولد عنها
حركه الهواء بما يسمى
بالرياح فهي تنتقل من مكان الضغط العالي
الى مكان الضغط المنخفض وكل ما زاد الفارق
زاد شده عصف الريح والعرب اسماء والرياح
على حسب الشده والضعف والاتجاه والمنفعه
والمضره الصرصر هي الرياح الشديده التي
لها صوت صرصره واما عادوا فاهلكوا بريح
صارصر عاتيه اللواقح هي الرياح التي تلقح
السحاب وينزل المطر وارسلنا الرياح لواقع
فانزلنا من السماء ماء فاسقيناكموه وما
انتم له بخازنين العقيم هي الرياح المفسده
وفي عادل ارسلنا عليهم الريح العقيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واهم الرياح عند العرب رياح الصبا وهي
الرياح الشماليه الشرقيه وتسمى عند العامه
بالرياح النعشيه لانها تهب من مطلع بناتي
نعش وهي من الرياح المبشره قال النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم نصرت بالصباح واهلكت عادل
بالدبور رياح النسري وهي الرياح الجنوبيه
الشرقيه رياح الهيفي وهي الرياح الجنوبيه
الغربيه ورياح الدبور هي الرياح الشماليه
الغربيه وهي الرياح التي اهلك الله بها
قوم عاد لاح الله اقواما يقولون اننا
وجدنا طوال الدهر للحب شافيه ولا هبت
الريح جنوب لارضها من الليل الا بنتي
حاليا
[موسيقى]
تؤكد وفاه احد المتظاهرين المعتقلين
باصابه خطيره نتيجه عن التعليم
اكثر من عشره ملايين
من اجل تنحي الملياردير الى الماسك عن
رئاسه تويتر
111 عاما لعصابه غسيل الاموال بينها
وبينهم السعوديه وزوجها الوافد بتوام
الاحتلال الملك
العربيه تتجول في قريه مسفاه العبريين
احدى اشهر القرى التراثيه والسياحيه في
سلطنه عمان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]